Hendrik poinar is an expert on ancient
DNA the genetic material that can remain
in a person's bones long after they die
in 2012 he traveled to body a pot
savetti to find victims of the Black
Death the plague or the Black Death
killed half of Europe's population
between 1348 and 1350 it also hit Italy
hard in 1348 the church at body of pots
of area and all Topacio was on a
pilgrimage route the pilgrims probably
carried the plague with them Hendrik
poinar knows a lot about the Black Death
he has reconstructed the genome of the
microbe that caused it Yersinia pestis
poinar wants to figure out what made
this strain so deadly in medieval times
and maybe help prevent a new epidemic
near the side of the church researchers
find teeth jaws and bones some of the
burrial trenches date back to the 14th
century just the right age for plague
one deep trench holds a jaw with teeth
still embedded in a wall of dirt this is
a big find
that's because teeth are the best source
of ancient DNA especially if they
haven't been contaminated by people
handling them but first they have to be
excavated archaeologist Giuseppe
virtuality uses a dental pick to try to
loosen the jaw this is delicate work
they can't damage the bone but poinar is
not ready to give up still the teeth
don't budge eventually the researchers
give up on the jaw the field season at
Bhatia puts a very is ending but all is
not lost when r is able to yank teeth
out of other ancient jaws he'll test
them looking for DNA from many pathogens
such as syphilis tuberculosis and the
plague ultimately poinar ends up with
about 40 teeth to take home to his lab
at McMaster University in Toronto and
when he gets home he gets a sweet
surprise Giuseppe virtue Lodi has
finally extracted that jaw and sent a
tooth along
eventually when our hopes to know for
sure just what microbe killed the people
of body apud savetti 700 years ago
you
you